bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi en séance
l'examen d'un projet de loi mettant en
oeuvre le principe de participation du
public posé par l'article 7 de la charte
de l'environnement
cet article c'est celui qui consacre
comme principe à valeur
constitutionnelle le droit pour chaque
personne non seulement d'accéder aux
informations environnementales mais
encore et surtout de participer à
l'élaboration des décisions publiques
qui ont un lien avec l'environnement
dans plusieurs décisions en effet en
2011 puis en juillet 2012
le conseil constitutionnel qui avait été
saisi deux questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité avait jugé que ce
principe de participation du public
n'était pas correctement appliqué le
texte entière donc toutes les
conséquences et souhaite donner à
l'article 7 de la charte de
l'environnement toute sa portée
et pour y parvenir le texte prévoit que
pour les textes mis en ligne les
observations du public qui sont
recueillis par voie électronique devront
être suivis de la publication de leurs
observations
alors les français pourront-ils
désormais participer activement à
l'élaboration des décisions publiques
touchant à l'environnement
en tout cas le débat est ouvert et c'est
maintenant sur public sénat la
discussion du projet de loi relatifs à
la mise en oeuvre du principe de
participation du public défini à
l'article 7 de la charte de
l'environnement dans la discussion
générale
la parole est à madame delphine batho
ministre de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie zalea parole
madame la ministre
g
quelles sont même réglementaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission du
développement durable raymond vall
madame la rapporteure laurence rossignol
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs toute personne a le droit
dans des conditions et les limites
définies par la loi d'accéder aux
informations relatives à l'environnement
détenues par les autorités publiques et
de participer à l'élaboration des
décisions publiques ayant une incidence
sur l'environnement proclame l'article 7
de la charte de l'environnement le
projet de loi que j'ai l'honneur de
présenter au nom du gouvernement
aujourd'hui propose de donner toute sa
portée à ces dispositions
constitutionnelles et de franchir une
nouvelle étape dans la dea dans la
construction d'une démocratie écologique
en 2004 la france a en effet consacré en
tant que principe à valeur
constitutionnelle le droit d'information
et de participation des citoyens aux
décisions concernant l'environnement
l'article 7 de la charte de
l'environnement un essai inscrit dans
notre constitution la substance du
principe de participation affirmé par la
convention darus ratifiée par la france
le 8 juillet 2002 et entré en vigueur le
6 octobre suivant cette convention en
donnant une assise à des droits nouveaux
à opérer une révolution fondamentale
dont nous n'avons pas encore fini de
tirer toutes les conséquences à tous
ceux qui ne voyaient dans
l'environnement qu'un empilement de
normes et d'outils de protection au
service d'une vision figée de la nature
elle a opposé que le respect de
l'environnement supposer bien plus que
cela qu'il se construisait au travers de
choix auquel les citoyens devaient être
pleinement associés et donc
l'environnement ne pouvait être protégés
sans démocratie au sens le plus fort du
terme en prévoyant que les informations
détenues par les autorités publiques
devait être transmise à tous la
convention darus a fait de la
transparence une des valeurs
essentielles de l'action publique en
matière d'environnement en exigeant que
le public soit placée au coeur du
processus décisionnel chaque fois qu est
engagé un projet ou envisager un acte
susceptible d'avoir un impact sur
l'environnement
elle a fait de la prise en compte de
l'intérêt des générations futures au
travers de la préservation de
l'environnement
un des nouveaux piliers de notre modèle
démocratique pour la première fois elle
a affirmé que parmi tous les enjeux
l'environnement avait une place à part
puisqu'il ne peut être cris pris en
compte sans débat ni adhésion citoyenne
les principes de la convention daru sont
peu à peu irrigué notre doigt mais ont
mis plus de temps à entrer dans nos
pratiques administratives
c'est tout le travail d'élaboration de
nos décisions normatives ou des
décisions individuelles relatives aux
grands projets qui devaient être revus
en profondeur
la tâche était difficile plusieurs
décisions du conseil constitutionnel ont
mis en évidence récemment le caractère
inachevé et incomplet de ces adaptations
législatives en exigeant qu'il y soit
remédié d'urgence le conseil
constitutionnel avait déjà eu l'occasion
de souligner la portée du principe
d'information et de participation du
public à l'occasion en particulier de
son examen de la loi sur les ogm il
avait rappelé que seul le législateur
était compétent pour définir les
conditions et les limites dans
lesquelles devaient s'exercer le droit
ainsi reconnu au public
puis le conseil d'état avait fait aussi
une application de ce principe en 2008
en annulant une procédure de
participation prévue par décret ces
décisions rendues nécessaires des
adaptations de notre réglementation
jusqu alors les procédures de
participation relevé en droit français
de la seule voie réglementaire
il a du fun il a fallu donc les rendre
législatives en outre ces procédures
demeurait lacunaire il n'y avait aucune
procédure par exemple pour les textes
réglementaires pris par l'administration
or il est bien évident qu'un texte
réglementaire peut avoir un impact sur
l'environnement en fixant de nouvelles
règles pour l'exercice d'activités
industrielles par exemple c'est la loi
grenelle 2 du 10 juillet 2010 qui a
opéré les premières modifications
rénover les enquêtes publiques et
introduit au code de l'environnement des
articles transversaux qui devait
s'appliquer lorsque aucune procédure
n'était prévu ce sont les articles l121
1 et l 122 du code de l'environnement
qui s'applique pourtant ces adaptations
sont restées insuffisantes et marquée
par une certaine confusion entre
information et participation
si les enquêtes publiques sont des
formes de participation du public
incontestable elle ne s'applique qu'à un
petit nombre de décisions relatives à
des projets importants par leur ampleur
et leur
pacte pour de multiples autres décisions
bien souvent le droit français ne
prévoient qu'une consultation d'un
organisme comprenant des représentants
des diverses parties prenantes donc une
forme de participation indirecte
ces insuffisances ont suscité des
recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel une série de décisions
rendues dans le cadre de la procédure de
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité ont ainsi déclaré
contraire à l'article 7 de la charte
certaines des dispositions du code de
l'environnement leur abrogation prendra
effet soit le 1er janvier soit le 1er
septembre 2013 selon les cas ce projet
de loi est donc marquée par l'urgence je
devrais même dire l'extrême urgence
puisque notre calendrier est très serré
des dispositions vont tomber le 1er
janvier prochain et nous ne pouvons pas
courir le risque d' asseoir sur des
dispositions censurées des décisions
importantes pour la vie économique et
sociale de notre pays
les censures du 14 octobre 2011 portait
en effet sur la procédure de
l'enregistrement qui s'applique à des
centaines dit cpe installations classées
pour l'environnement en france
j'ajoute que le conseil constitutionnel
devait statuer sur une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité
portant sur l'article 120 1 du code de
l'environnement d'ici la fin du mois de
novembre et nous pouvons attendre des
juridictions suprêmes qu'elle nous dise
ce que nous devons faire
il revient en effet aux législatures
d'assumer ses responsabilités et
d'assurer la sécurité juridique de
l'ensemble des décisions publiques dans
les meilleurs délais mais je veux aussi
souligner que cette contrainte de
l'urgence bien réel peut-être une
opportunité pas seulement pour pallier à
un manque mais pour accomplir ensemble
un nouveau progrès pour la démocratie
environnementale
ce projet de loi exige en effet que nous
nous rassemblions sur les grandes
valeurs qui doivent guider l'adaptation
de toutes nos procédures administratives
nous devons relever le défi de la
participation des citoyens avec
enthousiasme avec la conviction que
l'introduction de procédures de
démocratie participative simple utile
est absolument nécessaire dans le
domaine de l'environnement ou les
intérêts à long terme de notre société
et de la planète sont en cause
la feuille de route pour la transition
écologique sur laquelle le gouvernement
s'est engagé à
issu de la conférence environnementale
ainsi fixé l'ambition d'améliorer la
gouvernance environnementale et de
favoriser la participation effective des
citoyens
je veux citer d'abord sur l'enjeu veux
insister d'abord pardon sur l'ampleur du
champ couvert par le principe de
participation
en effet en rendant ces décisions le
conseil constitutionnel a défini un
champ d'application très large
les deux qpc numéro 2011 180 384 du 14
octobre 2011 concernaient des actes
réglementaires en matière dit cpe la qpc
2012 269 du 27 juillet 2012 a déclaré
contraire à la constitution avec effet
au 1er septembre 2013 des décisions
individuelles en censurant le quatrième
mans de l'article 411 2 du code de
l'environnement qui permet de prendre
des dérogations individuelles pour des
motifs scientifiques à l'interdiction de
porter des atteintes à certaines espèces
sauvages
la qpc 2012 270 du 27 juillet 2012
quant à elles concernaient des décisions
relatives à la délimitation des aires de
captage d'eau potable
donc ce que l'on appelle une décision
d'espèce c'est à dire ni réglementaire
ni individuelles consistant à définir
une zone dans laquelle s'applique telle
ou telle réglementation elle près doute
elle présente en outre l'intérêt de
porter sur une décision prise notamment
avec une collectivité depuis ces qpc
c'est bien l'ensemble des décisions
publiques
quelle que soit leur nature
réglementaire individuel ou d'espèces et
surtout quelle que soit l'autorité qui
les rend administrative de l'état
central ou déconcentrer mais aussi des
collectivités territoriales qui dès lors
qu'elles ont un impact sur
l'environnement peuvent faire l'objet
d'une censure du conseil constitutionnel
toutes ces décisions doivent donc être
au plus tard d'ici le 1er septembre 2013
rendu conforme à la constitution
en outre les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel nous impose de nous
interroger très concrètement sur la
qualité et les formes que doit revêtir
cette participation est de distinguer
très clairement la consultation d'un
organisme et la participation de tous
les principes ont été affirmés depuis
longtemps il faut maintenant les faire
vivre dans des formes concrètes sans
avoir expressément exclue d'une manière
générale toute forme de participation
indirecte du public à l'élaboration des
décisions et
une incidence sur l'environnement le
conseil constitutionnel a fait
clairement apparaître dans ses décisions
rendues notamment en matière
d'installations classées qu'une
disposition générale se bornant à
prévoir une publication du projet de
décision puis sa transmission à un
organe consultatif comportant des
représentants deux catégories de
personnes concernées n'assure pas la
mise en oeuvre du principe
constitutionnel de participation
l'article premier du projet de loi
modifie donc l'article health l120 1 du
code de l'environnement qui en l'absence
de procédure particulière organise la
participation du public à l'élaboration
des décisions réglementaires de l'état
et de ses établissements publics le
conseil constitutionnel ne s'est pas
prononcé directement sur la
constitutionnalité de cet article mais
je l'évoquais il il est il fait l'objet
d'une fragilité juridique puisque une
idée frappé d'une qpc qui est en train
d'être examinées le 1 de l'article l121
1 du code de l'environnement dans la
rédaction que lui donne le projet de loi
élargit donc le champ d'application de
cet article à l'ensemble des décisions
des personnes morales autres
qu'individuel ce qui exclut notamment
les décisions dites d'espèce le projet
modifie l'article l100 20 sur un point
important disparaît la mention des
décisions publiques ayant une incidence
directe et significative sur
l'environnement c'est la formulation qui
retenu est désormais celle de la charte
de l'environnement il s'agit d'une
avancée très importante puisque la
formulation actuelle était restrictives
et source d'ambiguïté et en ce qui
concerne la mode les modalités de
participation du public aux décisions
une mise à disposition par voie
électronique permettant de recueillir
les observations du public était déjà
prévu mais cette procédure est améliorée
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui les projets
sont mis en ligne sur un site pour une
durée minimale de 15 jours durant
laquelle le public peut formuler ses
observations pour permettre la prise en
compte des observations un délai minimal
est fixé de deux jours entre la fin de
la consultation l intervention de la
décision aucune disposition législative
ne définit la façon dont les
observations doivent être prises en
compte dans la nouvelle procédure
il y a toujours une mise à disposition
pour une même durée de 15 jours
c'est un point qui fait débat cette
durée est un minimum et peut être
allongée l'esprit de la convention darus
étant clairement de proportionner la
participation du public à l'importance
et à la complexité du projet la mise à
disposition du projet est accompagné
d'une notice explicative permettant aux
citoyens de comprendre le contexte et
les objectifs poursuivis
c'est la première nouveauté mais surtout
cette mise à disposition n'est qu'un
préalable à ce qui est en réalité
l'objectif de la participation c'est à
dire la prise en compte des observations
du public
désormais une synthèse écrites des
observations devra être effectuée par
l'autorité dont émane le projet et cette
synthèse devra également être rendu
public
ainsi les citoyens pourront par eux
mêmes constaté que leurs observations
ont été analysés et vérifier en toute
transparence
la façon dont elles auront été prises en
considération ils auront le projet
initial la synthèse des observations et
le projet final l'ensemble du processus
décisionnel devient transparent c'est
l'apport principal de cette nouvelle
procédure
j'ajoute que j'ai bien conscience que
cette procédure peut être encore
amélioré
je rappelle qu'elles se bornent à
définir un socle minimal commun qui peut
toujours être plus ambitieux selon les
décisions
l'analyse quantitative parce que c'est
un point à prendre en considération des
procédures de participation que
l'administration de mon ministère met en
oeuvre depuis 2010 figurent dans l'ain
dans l'étude d'impact qui est jointe au
projet de loi
ainsi si en matière d'ici peu les
observations du public qui sont souvent
le fait de professionnels ou
d'associations experte dépasse rarement
la dizaine en revanche les chiffres sont
très significatifs dans le domaine de
l'eau et de la faune 4984 observations
recueillies lors de la mise en ligne du
projet de décret relatifs au programme
d'action régionaux en vue de la
protection des eaux contre la prod
la pollution par les nitrates d'origine
agricole les projets de schémas
directeurs d'aménagement et de gestion
des eaux ont recueilli à eux tous 386
1505 observation le décret d'adoption
des orientations nationales de la trame
verte et bleue pour prendre un autre
exemple a recueilli 2704 observations on
peut se féliciter de ces chiffres qui
montrent une vitalité dont on parle peu
mais il faut être réaliste et imaginer
la charge de travail que représente le
traitement de plusieurs milliers
d'observations
le iii de l'article l 121 reprend le
cadre de l'actuelle qui prévoit la
possibilité d'enceinte et un cas
d'urgence de supprimer ou d'adapter la
consultation du public
enfin le 5 de cet article l121 reprend
le clarifiant les termes du 5 de
l'actuel article qui détermine les
intérêts en vue de la protection
desquels les modalités de la
participation du public peuvent être
adaptées je voudrais ici remercier tout
particulièrement la commission qui sous
l'impulsion de sa rapporteure laurence
rossignol a donné une ampleur nouvelle à
l'article 1er du projet de loi qui
définit ce socle minimal de procédure de
participation par voie électronique
amené à se développer dans les années
qui viennent
la commission a fait oeuvre utile et
ouvert des pistes très intéressantes
il est bon de rappeler ainsi qu'elle l'a
fait les objectifs de la participation
du public encore trop souvent confondue
avec l'information ou avec une
consultation purement formel ce qu'ils
sont des notions bien différente
il s'agit bien d'associer toute personne
à l'élaboration des décisions ayant un
impact sur l'environnement
loto l'autorité compétente reste bien
sûr maître de la décision mais elle doit
tenir compte des observations du public
ces règles générales sont ensuite
déclinés dans une procédure que la
commission a précisé en s'interrogeant
de façon très concrète sur le
déroulement de celle-ci étape par étape
comment ne pas exclure les personnes ne
disposant pas d'un ordinateur et d'une
connexion internet
comment faire en sorte que les
observations du public soit déposer en
toute transparence et surtout comment le
public peut-il s'assurer que ces
observations ont bien été prises en
compte
à toutes ces questions la commission a
répondu de façon pragmatique et positive
la démocratie ainsi progresser et aller
faites vous le savez de règles concrètes
et d'une infinie précision de détails
matériels qui ont chacun leur sens et je
remercie la commission de ces
améliorations même si bien sûr il pourra
y avoir des discussions sur tel ou tel
point
les articles 2 à 4 du projet de loi ont
pour objet d'apporter aux dispositions
législatives du code de l'environnement
concernés par les déclaration
d'inconstitutionnalité prenant effet le
1er janvier 2013
un site à des dispositions analogues
entaché du même vie soit du code de
l'environnement soit du code rural les
corrections
nécessaires pour assurer leur conformité
à l'article 7 de la charte de
l'environnement
l'article 2 abroge les dispositions de
l'article l 512,9 et l512 10 du code de
l'environnement qui se bornait à prévoir
la publication du projet de décision
avant sa transmission un organe
consultatif
de la même façon il y a la disparition
de ces procédures particulières de mise
à disposition du public des projets de
décision aura pour effet de rendre
applicable les dispositions transversale
de l'article l121 1 du code de
l'environnement dans la rédaction qui
sera issu du projet de loi
je ne reviens pas en détail sur les
différents articles ou trois quatre cinq
nous en viendrons nous les aborderons
dans la discussion il s'agit
d'adaptations à chaque fois notamment
pour le code rural et de la pêche
maritime de ces dispositions
je voulais peut-être insisté enfin sur
l'article 7 qui habilite le gouvernement
à prendre par ordonnance les
dispositions relevant du domaine de la
loi ayant pour objet de prévoir
conformément à l'art l'article 7 de la
charte les conditions et les limites de
la participation du public à
l'élaboration des décisions ayant une
incidence sur l'environnement autres que
celles incluses dans le 1 du fameux
article l121 1 du code de
l'environnement c'est-à-dire les
décisions individuelles de l'état et de
ses établissements publics et toutes les
décisions réglementaires d'espèces ou
individuels des collectivités locales
cet article 7 définit également
notamment en modifiant l'article l 122
du code de l'environnement les
conditions auxquelles les décisions
publiques ayant une incidence sur
l'environnement prise conformément un
acte ayant donné lieu à la participation
du public peuvent le cas échéant n'êtes
pas elle même soumise à participation du
public
si un texte support a donné lieu à une
procédure de participation le texte pris
en application pourrait évidemment en
être dispensé le gouvernement par cet
article 7 serait aussi autorisé à
prendre par ordonnance les dispositions
permettant d'étendre les dispositions de
la loi aux îles de wallis et futuna et
aux terres australes et antarctiques
françaises
je sais que le recours à une ordonnance
prise sur le fondement de l'article 38
de la constitution a fait débat lors de
l'examen du projet de loi en commission
je connais les réticences des
parlementaires a délégué ainsi leurs
pouvoirs législatifs à l'exécutif et je
souhaite donc vous rassurer sur les
intentions du gouvernement et prendre
devant vous
engagement extrêmement clair j'aurai
l'occasion à l'issue de sa discussion de
recevoir les représentants des
associations d'élus je leur dirai que le
recours à l'ordonnancé est liée à une
contrainte majeure de calendrier en
effet le conseil constitutionnel par sa
décision numéro 2012 269 du 27 juillet a
déclaré contraire à la constitution avec
effet au 1er septembre 2013 les
décisions individuelles de l'état de ses
établissements publics d'une part et
toutes les décisions des collectivités
territoriales d'autre part qui ne
respecteraient pas l'article 7 de la
charte de l'environnement
il est donc il existe donc un risque
d'insécurité juridique majeur pour
l'état comme pour les collectivités
territoriales
cependant je souhaite non seulement
associés les associations d'élus mais
aussi le parlement aux travaux
préparatoires à la rédaction de cette
ordonnance
je proposerai donc si le président en
est d'accord de consulter régulièrement
votre commission du développement
durable tout au long de ce processus
en ce qui concerne les collectivités
territoriales je veux indiquer dès à
présent que les règles qui les
concerneront seront adaptés et ne seront
en aucun cas plus lourde que celle qui
s'impose à l'état
j'ai pris en compte l'urgence et dès ma
prise de fonction le travail
d'élaboration de ce projet de loi a été
entrepris mais dans le même temps j'ai
estimé qu'il n'aurait pas été
raisonnable d'imposer sans réflexion ni
concertation préalable aux collectivités
locales des dispositions auxquelles
elles doivent être préparées et qui
doivent être adaptées à leurs
particularités géographiques
démographiques ou technologiques
si à l'échelle d'une grande ville
organisé une vaste consultation par
internet est un moyen approprié de faire
participer le public
en revanche ce n'est pas nécessairement
le cas dans une petite commune rurale où
tous les habitants ne sont pas encore
connectés au haut débit
dans ce cas une forme de réunions
publiques locales serait mieux adapté à
une transcription législative précipité
j'ai donc préféré un travail dans la
concertation débouchant sur une
ordonnance
je veux ajouter que je veux que
l'écologie ne soit pas vécu comme une
contrainte
et c'est trop souvent le cas du fait il
faut le reconnaître d'un certain un
empilement des textes réglementaires et
des procédures qui s'ajoutent les unes
aux autres
beaucoup d'élus locaux mais aussi de
chefs d'entreprise mon nom fait part
concernant le bilan du grenelle de
l'environnement
c'est pourquoi lors de la conférence
environnementale a été discutée la
nécessité d'un processus de
modernisation du droit de
l'environnement avec un haut niveau
d'exigence écologique qui amusent à mes
yeux n'est pas incompatible avec des
procédures lisible et efficace des états
généraux de la modernisation du droit de
l'environnement seront donc organisées
au printemps prochain pour entreprendre
une réforme de notre droit de
l'environnement qui ne peut continuer à
empiler mais les procédures de débats
dans quête de consultation et de
participation sauf à risquer la
paralysie de toute décision
ce sera l'objet de ces états généraux
auxquels je souhaiterait associer
pleinement les élus il y aura donc
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs un acte 2 de la
construction d'une démocratie
environnementale moderne dès à présent
nos lois doivent être conformes à notre
conception d'une démocratie écologique
avancé aux valeurs que nous avons
inscrit dans notre constitution
notre loi fondamentale n'énonce pas des
principes théoriques
elle proclame en matière d'information
et de participation aux décisions des
droits concrets inaliénables dont
dispose chaque citoyen et dont il nous
appartient désormais d'assurer
l'effectivité j'espère que la discussion
permettra encore d'améliorer ce projet
de loi et que nous pourrons tous être
rassemblés autour de cette ambition
merci madame la ministre dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
madame laurence rossignol rapporteur de
la commission du développement durable
des infrastructures de l'équipement et
de l'aménagement du territoire
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
du développement durable l'aménagement
du territoire et des transports mes
chers collègues
l'objectif du projet de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui est d'assurer la
mise en oeuvre effective du principe de
participation du public consacré à
l'article 7 de la charte de
l'environnement
le texte dont le sénat a été saisie le 3
octobre 2012 en première lecture a été
soumis à la consultation du public du 11
au 24 septembre dernier en application
du principe de participation qu'il temps
lui-même à garantir ce projet de loi
s'inscrit pleinement dans le cadre de la
feuille de route pour la transition
écologique établi à l'issue de la
conférence environnementales et qui
appelle à une participation effective du
public ainsi qu'un rôle renforcé des
citoyens dans la mise en oeuvre et le
suivi des politiques publiques
c'est effectivement une nécessité en
matière environnementale et je me
réjouis que le gouvernement en fasse une
de ses priorités
tirant notamment les conclusions des
quatre censure du conseil
constitutionnel ce projet de loi a donc
pour but de définir les conditions et
les limites de la participation du
public aux décisions ayant une incidence
sur l'environnement
pour éclairer les enjeux de ce texte je
rappellerai d'abord que la jeunesse du
principe de participation du public est
déjà ancienne ce principe a été affirmé
de longue date en droit international
dès la déclaration de rio en 1992 et est
rappelé que la meilleure façon de
traiter les questions d'environnement et
d'assurer la participation de tous les
citoyens au niveau qui convient la
convention de la russe signé le 25 juin
90 par la france vise de son côté à
garantir le droit à l'information des
citoyens en matière environnementale
leur participation au processus
décisionnel ainsi que leur accès à la
justice
de nombreux pays de nombreux états ont
déjà mis en oeuvre le principe de
participation
le modèle est encore aujourd'hui les
états unis où l'administratif procédure
act prévoit que depuis 1946 une
procédure extrêmement détaillée de
participation s'appliquant à la majorité
des textes réglementaires quelles que
soient leurs sujets traités est
obligatoire au québec un bureau
d'audience publique permet depuis 1918
de consulter la population sur les
dossiers relatifs à l'environnement et
au projet
structure en france la consécration du
principe de participation est intervenue
après l'adoption de la charte de
l'environnement en 2004 à dos et en 2005
à la constitution dans son article 7 la
charte ne dispose que toute personne a
le droit dans les conditions et les
limites définies par la loi d'accéder
aux informations relatives à
l'environnement détenues par les
autorités publiques et de participer à
l'élaboration des décisions publiques
ayant une incidence sur l'environnement
la mise en oeuvre de cet article a été
codifié à l'occasion de la loi grenelle
2 cet article s'applique lorsque aucun
dispositif particulier de participation
n'est prévu comme par exemple une
enquête publique
il prévoyait que toutes les décisions et
internet une incidence directe est
significatif sur l'environnement soient
soumises à participation à l'occasion
des décisions rendues dans le cadre des
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité le conseil
constitutionnel a prononcé la non
conformité à la constitution de quatre
dispositifs de participation spécifiques
prévues dans le code de l'environnement
et présentant pour la plupart de fortes
similitudes avec le dispositif de
l'article l121 1 et il a également jugé
que les décisions individuelles devait
au même titre que les décisions
réglementaires l addition d'espèces
faire l'objet d'une participation du
public
l'abrogation des dispositions concernées
interviendra donc selon les cas au 1er
janvier au 1er septembre 2013
une autre décision du conseil
constitutionnel devrait intervenir d'ici
la fin du mois de novembre cette fois ci
sur la constitutionnalité de l'article l
121 et il devrait très probablement
subir le même sort je me félicite donc
qu'avec ce projet doit le gouvernement
anticipe comme il convient cette
décision c'est donc dans ce calendrier
ce cadre contraint que se situe l'examen
du présent projet de loi
c'est aussi pour le gouvernement comme
pour nous l'occasion de proposer des
modalités d'application véritablement
effective du principe de participation
du public
c'est dans cet esprit que notre
commission s'est saisi du projet de loi
son article 1er réécrit l'article l 121
1 du code de l'environnement qui est au
coeur du dispositif de participation
il anticipe ans à la décision à venir du
conseil constitutionnel le champ
d'application de l'article limitée
actuellement aux seules décisions
réglementaires de l'état et de ses
établissements publics
et étendu à l'ensemble de leurs
décisions autres qu'individuel seront
ainsi concernés par exemple les projets
de décrets en matière de police de l'eau
les arrêtés concernant l'ouverture de la
chasse ou encore les arrêtés relatifs
aux prescriptions générales applicables
aux installations classées il ne s'agit
en aucun cas de superposer une nouvelle
procédure de participation au dispositif
existant dans quêtes publiques ou de
concertation cet article l121 et
supplétifs et ne s'appliquera qu'en
l'absence de procédures spécifiques de
participation il prévoit qu'une
procédure permettant de recueillir
directement les observations du public
devra être suivi pour toute décision
ayant une incidence sur l'environnement
l'administration aura obligation de
publier une synthèse des observations
reçues les articles 2 à 5 du texte
modifie plusieurs procédures
particulières de participation du public
prévues dans le code de l'environnement
et le code rural notamment en matière
d'installation cassé ou encore de zones
d'alimentation des captages d'eau
potable dans tous les cas l'article l121
devient le droit commun applicable
l'article 6 modules dans le temps
l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau
dispositif qui prendra effet au 1er
janvier 2013
il est en effet important que les
décisions abrogée sans remplacer à cette
date et que les procédures de
participation en cours ne soit pas
entachée de nullité
enfin l'article 7 oblige le gouvernement
à prendre par ordonnance les mesures
nécessaires pour prévoir la
participation du public aux décisions
autres que celles prévues à l'article l
121 du code de l'environnement à savoir
les décisions individuelles émanant de
toutes les personnes publiques et des
décisions réglementaires et d'espèces
émanant des personnes autres que l'état
par exemple les collectivités
territoriales ou les autorités
administratives indépendantes
la commission du développement durable
adopté un certain nombre d'amendements
proposés par sa rapporteure et aussi par
plusieurs autres de ses membres afin de
renforcer la portée du dispositif
un premier amendement inscrit au début
de l'article l 121 les inscrits pardon
au début de l'article 120 les objectifs
et les principes de la participation du
public
il nous a semblé en effet utile de les
expliciter et de bien faire comprendre
aussi bien au grand public
administration l'importance et l'intérêt
de cette participation
un deuxième amendement a précisé le
contenu de l'année
deux présentations jointe au projet de
décision qui devra préciser le contexte
dans lequel la décision est prise
cet amendement mettant en oeuvre en
corollaire le corollaire du principe de
participation du public à savoir le
droit à l'information en matière
environnementale un troisième amendement
à porter la durée minimale de
participation à 21 jours par voie
postale et 30 jours par voie
électronique
la possibilité de contributions par voie
postale est en effet importante pour
n'exclure aucun citoyen de la
participation
par ailleurs le délai minimal de 15
jours initialement prévus a semblé trop
court à la commission pour permettre au
public de prendre à la fois connaissance
de la consultation et de formuler
utilement ses observations un quatrième
amendement vise à rendre obligatoire la
publicité des observations effectuées
sur le projet de décision
cette publicité généralement la norme
dans tous les pays disposant de
procédure de participation abouti comme
les etats unis se doit permettre une
participation plus efficace plus
transparente et moins verticale
la commission a adopté un cinquième
amendements sont promotion notre
collègue kevin didier afin de prévoir la
transmission conseils municipaux des
projets de décisions les concernant
il disposerait alors d'un délai d'un
mois pour se prononcer faute de quoi
leur avis sur est réputé favorable ce
les dalles led un mois est calqué sur
celui laissé au public pour formuler ses
observations et n'allons donc pas la
procédure de participation
trop souvent en effet des décisions
ayant une incidence sur l'environnement
sont prises sans même que les communes
en soit informé la commission a
conscience des éventuelles difficultés
pratiques de mise en oeuvre d'un tel
dispositif de transmission mais il
s'agit d'un problème que nous souhaitons
va pouvoir traiter au cours de l'examen
cet après midi en séance publique
un sixième amendement est adopté en en
vue du à particules et la consultation
s'il ya lieu d'un organe collégial avec
la participation directe du public
l'organe consultatif devra disposer de
la synthèse des observations du public
avant de rendre lui-même son avis s'agit
d'éviter des consultations parallèle
dans lesquelles les informations ne se
croise pas est une expression du tout de
ligue qui n'arriverait pas jusqu'aux
oreilles des comités chargés aimait trop
d'émettre un avis sur la même le même
projet de décision
le septième amendements portent sur la
méthode par laquelle administration
démontrant qu'elle a tenu compte des
observations du public
il ne paraît ni envisageable ni
souhaitable d'imposer une obligation
générale de motivation des décisions
publiques
cette obligation est rappelons-le heures
restreinte aux décisions
visuel défavorables depuis la loi du 11
juillet 1919
en revanche il est possible de prévoir
que l'administration indique dans la
synthèse des observations qu'elle doit
effectuer celle des observations qu'elle
a choisi de suivre
enfin il a été adopté un amendement de
précisions concernant le critère de
l'urgence qui peut dans certains cas
justifier que ne soit pas procéder à une
procédure de participation ou d'en
réduire les délais la commission a par
ailleurs assuré deux articles
additionnels un article additionnel
après l'article 2 afin de mettre en
conformité à la constitution des
dispositions qui avaient été oubliés
dans le projet de loi concernant les
canalisations des transports et des
plans de prévention des risques naturels
prévisibles
ainsi qu'un article 10 ionel après
l'article 4 dans le but de compléter la
composition des comités régionaux des
trames vertes et bleues
ces comités n'inclut pas à l'heure
actuelle de représentants de certaines
parties prenantes comme par exemple les
représentants des usagers la nature
l'état ou encore les organismes de
recherche
ce nouvel article vise à rendre leurs
compositions conformes à l'esprit
d'ouverture de la participation
indirecte du public par le biais
d'organes collégiaux voilà monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le sens des travaux de la
commission du développement durable
soutient la ministre que notre
commission à une discussion approfondie
sur l'article 7 et le recours aux
ordonnances
vous avez compris la sensibilité du
parlement à l'usagé ordonnance et vous
avez dans votre intervention liminaire
indiqué à la fois votre perception et la
légitimité de cette inquiétude mais
aussi vous avez souhaité nous apporter
toutes les garanties possibles sur la
consultation l'association du parlement
et le respect des ordonnances de
l'esprit de l'article 1 je vous en
remercie et je souhaite que ces
précisions que vous avez apporté soit
entendu et débattu cet après-midi par
nos collègues
je rappellerai enfin pour finir que même
si ce texte est née d'une sanction du
conseil constitutionnel imposant une
mise en conformité rapide du code de
l'environnement
ils n'en constituent pas moins
l'occasion de rendre pleinement effectif
le principe fondamental de participation
du public c'est une petite révolution
que nous faisons chaque jour c'est une
révolution pour les administrations une
révolution pour toutes les autorités et
c'est une révolution qu'il faut porte
et c'est notre rôle aujourd'hui et je
souhaite qu'avec ce texte nous ferons un
pas de plus vers la mise en place d'une
véritable démocratie environnementale
qui est aujourd'hui la condition d'une
démocratie moderne
merci mesdames la rapporteure dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole et à monsieur à la houppe r
percy
monsieur le président madame la ministre
de l'écologie du développement durable
et de l'énergie mes chers collègues en
bâtissant les fondements d'une
démocratie économique et sociale le
constituant de 1946 s'est donné pour
mission de prolonger l'oeuvre des grands
républicains de la révolution française
il a ainsi contribué à traduire dans le
droit une certaine vision de la
démocratie celle d'un système de
gouvernement dans lequel la
participation de chacun procède non
seulement d'un geste politique
le suffrage mais aussi d'une philosophie
de la vie qui soit à même de s'exprimer
qu'on traitement et de manière continue
dans tous les domaines de l'action
publique
bien que plus tardive la notion de
démocratie environnementale procède de
cette même philosophie celle d'une
démocratie dans laquelle des formes
participatives de gouvernement complète
l'expression éminente essentiel durable
mais aussi ponctuel et général du
suffrage politique
sa construction s'inscrit ainsi dans une
évolution plus globale d'apprendre
d'approfondissement de la démocratie
dite administrative qui complète et
enrichit la pratique démocratique dans
son ensemble la notion de démocratie
environnementale est en effet une
composante importante développement de
la démocratie est ainsi une source de
renouvellement du pacte social elle
traduit l'émergence d'une nouvelle forme
de citoyenneté dont l'objet non sans un
certain paradoxe n'est pas tant le
gouvernement de la cité que la
participation de chacun dans la
détermination de la chose publique
la démocratie environnementale repose
essentiellement sur l'affirmation de
deux droits récent le droit
d'information et celui de participation
qui figurent tous deux à l'article 7 de
la charte de l'environnement projet
d'ailleurs un initié par le président
jacques chirac
ces droits sont des droits de
citoyenneté en ce sens que leur exercice
à l'instar de la citoyenneté que l'on
pourrait qualifier de politique révèle
d'une démarche de légitimer légitimation
de l'action publique
tel est le cas des procédures
administratives au travers desquels le
public participe
à la formation de la décision
administrative et donc d'une expression
de l'intérêt général
ces procédures sont particulièrement
développés lorsqu'il s'agit de parcs de
préparer et de mettre en oeuvre des
projets particuliers l'enquète public
par exemple s'impose aujourd'hui
préalablement à tous les projets ayant
une incidence sur l'environnement
son objet est de permettre au public de
se prononcer sur l'opportunité d'un
projet il en va de même de la procédure
de concertation
originalement liées au droit de
l'urbanisme mais qui trouve aujourd'hui
des prolongements dans le domaine du
droit de l'environnement soit
lorsqu'aucune autre procédure
participative n'est prévue soit par
exemple dans le cadre de l'élaboration
des études d'impact la formation la
formulation même de l'article l 123 16
du code de l'environnement qui concerne
les études d'impact exprime de manière
éclairante
l'objet de cette procédure qui est
d'associer le public à l'élaboration du
projet c'est à dire la détermination de
l'intérêt public qui s'attache à sa
réalisation
le débat public enfin organisée à
l'occasion de la préparation des projets
publics ou privés qui ont des impacts
significatifs sur l'environnement a pour
objet même la participation du public
pendant toute la phase d'élaboration de
ces projets cette notion de
participation comme l'idée même de débat
atteste la relation évidente entre la
procédure de débat public et la pratique
démocrate démocratique tout autant que
la mise en oeuvre de projets
particuliers l'application du principe
de participation à la procédure
d'élaboration des actes réglementaires
illustre la dynamique de la démocratie
environnementale qui conduit associer le
public à la détermination de l'intérêt
général
lors de l'examen du projet de loi
portant engagement national pour
l'environnement dit grenelle 1
le conseil d'état a en effet adopté
conformément à la lettre et à l'esprit
de la charte de l'environnement une
interprétation à la fois large et
pragmatique de la notion de décisions
publiques ayant une incidence sur
l'environnement qui figure à l'article 7
de cette charte
il a estimé que cette notion recouvre
est effectivement les actes de nature
réglementaire
y compris le cas échéant les ordonnances
la loi dit grenelle 2 du 12 juillet 2010
a consacré cette pratique en intronisant
en introduisant pardon dans le code de
l'environnement un article l121 qui
prévoit désormais que les décisions
réglementaires de l'état et de sézanne
d'établissement public sont soumises à
participation du public lorsqu'elles ont
une incidence directe est significatif
sur l'environnement
sous l'effet de ces nouveaux droits de
citoyenneté la démocratie
environnementale conduit à l'émergence
d'une nouvelle forme de citoyenneté
l'idée de citoyenneté sur laquelle
repose la démocratie dite politique est
à l'origine le corollaire de l'exercice
de la suite souveraineté c'est-à-dire de
la participation au gouvernement de la
cité
en ce sens la citoyenneté telle qu'elle
s'est construite dans un cadre étatique
est intrinsèquement liée à la détention
des droits civils et politiques dont la
jouissance est indissociable de
l'appartenance à une nation
cette nouvelle forme de citoyenneté qui
s'exprime dans la démocratie
environnementale diffère de cette
citoyenneté politique elle en diffère en
premier lieu en ce qu'elle n'est pas
liée du moins pas directement un
exercice de la souveraineté nationale
même si l'état en est bien évidemment le
lieu principal d'expression les droits
de participation et de transparence qui
sont au coeur de la démocratie
environnementale procède en effet
directement de la même notion
d'environnement
elles sont la contrepartie ou plutôt le
prolongement du droit de vivre dans un
environnement équilibré et respectueux
de la santé a affirmé par l'article
premier de la charte de l'environnement
mais aussi de devoir de toute personne
de prendre part à la préservation et à
l'amélioration de l'environnement
exprimé à l'article 2 de la charte la
citoyenneté environnementale n'est donc
pas liée à l'exercice de la souveraineté
mais à la seule existence d'un bien
public d'un patrimoine commun des êtres
humains
en ce sens elle est une citoyenneté de
la chose publique par nature cette
nouvelle forme de citoyenneté est
dissociée de la citoyenneté politique
dans la mesure où les droits qui en sont
l'expression ne sont pas à la différence
des droits politiques les droits liés à
la construction d'une société politique
dans le cadre de l'état et ne sont donc
pas des droits conférés par l'état ou
inhérents par lui ils sont nés en effet
des droits fondamentaux dont chaque être
humain dispose et qu'il peut opposer à
la puissance publique
c'est ce qu'ont affirmé en 2008 le
conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel en reconnaissant la
valeur constitutionnelle de l'article 7
de la charte de l'environnement
la consécration du principe de
participation par l'article 7 qui
dispose que je cite toute personne a le
droit dans les conditions les limites
définies par la loi d'accéder aux
informations relatives à l'environnement
détenues par les autorités politiques et
de participer à l'élaboration des
décisions politiques ayant une incidence
sur l'environnement les conditions
d'application de cet article on était
encadré par la loi
la mise en oeuvre de l'article 7 a été
codifié à l'occasion de la loi grenelle
2 à l'article l 121 1 du code de
l'environnement
cet article s'applique lorsque qu'aucun
autre dispositif particulier de
participation n'est prévu de type
enquête publique par exemple l'article
l121 prévoit que toutes les décisions
ayant une incidence directe est
significatif sur l'environnement sont
soumises à participation le caractère de
droits fondamentaux des principes de
participation une transparence procède
en outre de leur reconnaissance par des
conventions internationales relatives à
l'environnement
la déclaration de rio de 1990 de 92
pardon et son principe 10 qui rappelle
que la meilleure façon de traiter les
considère questions d'environnement et
d'assurer la participation de tous les
citoyens au niveau qui convient la
convention d'un russe signé par la
france le 25 juin 1998 dont les
paragraphes 2 3 et 7 de l'article 6 sont
d'application directe vise à garantir le
droit à l'information des citoyens en
matière environnementale
leur participation au processus
décisionnel et leur accès à la justice
ces derniers imposent donc aux autorités
publiques notamment d'informer le public
comme il convient de manière efficace et
en temps voulu
lorsqu'un processus décisionnel touchant
l'environnement est engagé en tant que
droits fondamentaux
ces nouveaux droits de citoyenneté sont
donc attribuée à toute personne
indépendant de sa seat nationalité à la
différence de la citoyenneté politique
comme l'attestent la notion de public
auquel s'adresse les mesures
d'information et de participation
cette notion se définit uniquement par
référence à l'intérêt des personnes
concernées par les procédures
décisionnelles en matière
d'environnement
cette nouvelle forme de citoyenneté qui
forme qui fondent la démocratie
environnementale ne remplace pas la
citoyenneté politique
sa vocation est au contraire de la
compléter et de contribuer ainsi à un
enrichissement du pacte social pour cela
à l'aune des modalités concrètes
d'organisation et des principes qui
guident la démocratie politique
la pratique de cette nouvelle
citoyenneté doit être encore enrichi
afin de la rendre plus effectives et
afin qu'elle mette pleinement en oeuvre
le principe d'égalité
c'est dans ce sens que les récentes
décisions rendues par le conseil
constitutionnel
dans le cadre des questions prioritaires
de constitutionnalité ombre prononcer la
non conformité à la constitution de
quatre dispositifs de participation
spécifiques prévues dans le code de
l'environnement
il a également jugé que les décisions
individuelles devraient au même titre
que les décisions réglementaires et les
décisions des espèces faire l'objet
d'une participation du public
l'abrogation des dispositions concernées
interviendra selon les cas au 1er
janvier au 1er septembre 2013 afin
d'éviter la censure problème le d'artix
120 1 le présent projet de loi permet de
proposer des modalités d'application
véritablement effective du principe de
participation du public et de traiter
les questions environnementales en
garantissant la transparence et
l'effectivité des décisions publiques
cette nouvelle forme de ness 2
citoyenneté dont elle permet
l'expression qui procède directement de
l'existence même de la chose publique
complète de manière continue et
concrètes sans lien avec l'idée de
souveraineté l'expression de la
citoyenneté politique entre deux
manifestations du suffrage c'est pour
toutes ces raisons que le groupe ump
votera pour ce texte merci de votre
attention
merci monsieur là on perd dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole et à
madame evelyne didier
mexès
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'adoption de la
charte de l'environnement fut un signe
fort pour une meilleure prise en compte
des préoccupations environnementales
dans les textes marquants notamment la
reconnaissance du droit de toute
personne à accéder aux informations et
de participer à la prise de décision des
autorités publiques en la matière sa
valeur juridique a été reconnu par
plusieurs décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
aujourd'hui et par ce projet de loi nous
en tirons les conséquences législatives
notamment au regard des dispositions qui
ont été censurés et qui méritent une
action rapide du gouvernement
ainsi la charte de l'environnement son
article 7 impose la participation du
public à toute décision ayant des
incidences environnementales
récemment vous êtes engagé madame la
ministre durant la conférence
environnementale qui s'est tenue les 14
et 15 septembre dernier à paris au
renforcement du rôle du public dans la
mise en oeuvre et le suivi des
politiques publiques en reconnaissant la
nécessité d'une participation effective
du public
nous sommes favorables à cet objectif
qui permet une plus grande transparence
une démocratisation des politiques
publiques en matière d'environnement et
nous fondons favorable aux objectifs
définis par le présent projet de loi qui
opèrent à la fois une clarification de
la procédure ainsi qu'une meilleure
lisibilité pour nos concitoyens il faut
savoir au préalable que ce projet de loi
définit la procédure minimal de
participation du public un certain
nombre de décisions relevant de
procédure particulière et notamment de
l' enquête publique bouchardeau le
travail approfondie effectuée en
commission a permis d'enrichir très
sensiblement les textes et nous
soutenons nous souhaitons souligner ici
le climat constructif
instauré par notre rapporteur par le
président également animé par la volonté
d'arriver au meilleur consensus
c'est donc une satisfaction est par
ailleurs ne certains de nos amendements
ayant été adoptées à ce moment là nous
étions satisfaits des travaux en
commission depuis les choses ont bougé
et
il va peut-être y avoir quelques
décalage entre ce que je voulais dire
et puis ce que j'ai envie de dire
maintenant compte tenu de nos travaux
tout récent n'est ce pas mais que
voulez-vous nous avons découvert des
amendements il y a à peine une demi
heure j'arrive au contenu du projet de
loi concernant particulièrement le
périmètre d'application du présent
dispositif
même si nous prenons acte de
l'élargissement de l'application de
cette procédure aux décisions d'espèces
à savoir les décisions concernant un
domaine restreint
nous continuons de regretter que la
procédure ainsi défini ne traite pas des
décisions individuelles qui feront
l'objet vous nous l'avez expliqué d'une
ordonnance selon l'article 7 du projet
de loi
nous contestons habituellement est très
régulièrement le recours aux ordonnances
c'est pourquoi nous avons posé même
lorsqu'il s'agissait d'un autre
gouvernement est dieu sait s'il en a usé
et abusé des ordonnances s'il vous plaît
c'est pourquoi nous avons posé en
commission la question de savoir
pourquoi la procédure ainsi défini ne
pouvait pas s'appliquer aux décisions
individuelles
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure madame
la ministre vouloir associer notre
commission à la rédaction des
ordonnances c'est pourquoi je vous en
donne acte et je n'irai pas plus loin
sur cet aspect là ce qui ne m'empêchera
pas de continuer à contester d'une
manière générale les ordonnances par
ailleurs ensuite le périmètre des actes
visés doit être élargi à ceux émanant
des autorités administratives
indépendantes dont les conséquences en
matière environnementale sont
importantes
il s'agit notamment des actes de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire ou encore
de l' agence nationale des fréquences
je nous proposions un nouvel amendement
mais cette question sera abordée à
l'examen puisque d'autres amendements du
gouvernement vont venir
j'allais dire impacter notre propre
amendement sur la procédure telle que
définie à l'article l 121 nous avons
évolué en commission ainsi nous étions
nous étions satisfaits que la commission
ait convenu avec nous de la nécessité
porté à 30 jours au lieu de 15
le délai octroyé au public pour disposer
de l'information et formules formaliser
un avis cette période étant ramené à 21
jours pour les avis rendus par voie
postale pour des raisons techniques
depuis le gouvernement a proposé un
amendement nous allons donc y revenir
madame la rapporteure vous avez entendu
notre demande de motiver la décision
définitive
il nous semble en effet que la
motivation permet de rendre compte
concrètement des observations du public
nous avons enrichi le présent projet de
loi par l'adoption d'un amendement
déposé par notre groupe permettant
d'affirmer le principe d'information et
de participation des élus locaux aux
décisions ayant une incidence sur
l'environnement
depuis les choses ont évolué et nous
allons donc y revenir en commission j'ai
évoqué cette question parce qu'il en a
dans la commune dont je suis maire nous
avons eu à subir j'emploie ce mot une
procédure d' enquête d'une enquête pour
la forme
enquête qui s'est déroulé en été et en
réalité nous n'avions pas été avisé que
nous étions dans ces périmètres d'
enquête et il y a fallu la vigilance
d'une association pour que nous en
soyons informés et que le conseil
municipal puisse se prononcer ce qui
explique les amendements que j'ai
déposée et donc j'aimerais tout de même
que même si on ne prend pas l'amendement
l'état parce que visiblement ça pose des
questions j'aimerais qu'on trouve une
réponse concrète à ce sujet tel que
défini à l'article 1er la mise à
disposition du projet de décision ainsi
que la note de présentation publique se
font uniquement de manière numérique
c'est une autre question ce qui nous
semble encore insuffisants pour garantir
l'information de tous
trop de nos concitoyens ne disposent pas
d'un accès internet
même si je reconnais qu'internet a
grandement contribué à informer un
nombre croissant de personnes et ça il
ne faut pas le nier et nous attendons
madame la ministre donc d engagement de
votre part de favoriser l'accès
aux technologies numériques permettant
ainsi une participation effective du
plus grand nombre aux prises de
décisions ayant des incidences
environnementales
de la même manière l'information du
lancement de ce type de procédure doit
faire l'objet d'une publicité affichée
dans les mairies en tout cas c'est notre
avis lorsque ces mairies sont concernés
bien évidemment il ne s'agit pas de
d'afficher tout ce qui peut paraître
mais aussi en préfecture les discussions
en commission nous ont confirmé qu'il
s'agissait d' une préoccupation partagée
à laquelle nous vous nous souhaitons que
vous y répond que vous répondiez d'autre
part la définition de l'urgence qui
permet de ne pas consulter public nous
semblait trop large et pour pouvoir
donner lieu à des abus
enfin nous attendons avec impatience la
refonte annoncée du code minier qui
permettra nous le demandons de rendre
publiques les décisions d'accorder des
permis d'explorer ou d'exploiter le
sous-sol en fait nous allons y revenir
également puisque le gouvernement a
apporté des précisions et un amendement
rectifié va arriver tout à l'heure nous
sommes soulagés que madame les midis
vous ayez continuer de dire qu'il y
avait interdiction d'exploration des gaz
et huiles de schiste
nous espérons qu'à la remise du rapport
gallois qui prône le développement de la
recherche sur les techniques
d'exploitation des hydrocarbures de
roche
considérant la présence de ces
ressources fossiles comme une
opportunité pour la compétitivité de
notre pays ne vous fera pas changer
d'avis interdire l'exploration et
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures de
roche est un impératif environnemental
auquel les sénateurs du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen comme
les élus et les habitants des
territoires concernés sont
particulièrement sensibles dans la tente
de la refonte du code milliers et parce
qu'en commission sur tous les bancs nous
nous sommes accordés sur le fait qu'il
existe un vide juridique préjudiciable
nous proposons que la procédure d'octroi
du permis de recherche ainsi que celle
de trois de concessions jeu on verra que
les concessions sont déjà soumises à
procédure mais en tout cas que nous
trouvions une solution pour que les élus
comme la population soit informée la
transition écologique que nous appelons
de nos voeux ne se fera pas sans
associer les citoyens
aux procédures de décision publique nous
espérons que nos travaux en séance
publique permettront encore d'enrichir
ce texte qui dès à présent reçoit notre
approbation
je vous remercie merci madame evelyne
didier dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur henri
tandonnet
monsieur le président madame le ministre
madame la rapporteure monsieur le
président messire collègues
le projet de loi qui nous est présentée
était pour le moins attendu attendu par
le conseil constitutionnel qui s'est
déjà exprimée à quatre reprises sur la
question de la participation du public
aux décisions publiques ayant une
incidence sur l'environnement
il est donc nécessaire de légiférer pour
limiter l'insécurité juridique lié aux
décisions du conseil attendu par les
législateurs que nous sommes car la
charte de l'environnement nous sommes et
d'encadrer et de légiférer sur les
dispositifs d'information et de
consultation du public
nous devions donc nous saisir de ce
sujet attendu pour les citoyens même
pour qui ce texte apporte de nouveaux
droits mais aussi une nouvelle
responsabilité dans la prise de la
décision publique
sans revenir intégralement sur les
dispositions qui ont été exposés avant
moi j'aimerais dans un premier temps
apporter mon soutien aux objectifs de ce
texte
ensuite pointé du doigt des difficultés
juridiques du chambres d'application du
texte et de surcroît à une procédure
d'ordonnancé que l'on ne peut accepter
enfin notre commission du développement
durable à soulever différents problèmes
que nous devons résoudre en séance avec
je l'espère l'éclairage du gouvernement
tout d'abord ce projet de loi répond à
une double exigence constitutionnelle et
en matière de développement durable
comme la rapporteure de la commission
l'a rappelé le principe de participation
du public est au coeur des exigences en
matière de développement durable
lorsqu'elle a elle-même pacte
environnemental la décision publique
qu'elles viennent de l'état de ses
établissements des collectivités
territoriales concerne chaque citoyen
plus que dans toutes les autres matières
ainsi la participation active des
citoyens aux processus décisionnels
constitué un progrès démocratique une
avancée dans la transparence que chacun
peut saluer et soutenir du sommet de rio
en 92 à la loi barnier de 95 en passant
par l'adoption de la charte de
l'environnement 2004 nous pouvons tous
nous réjouir des progrès réalisés dans
cette matière ce projet de loi s'inscrit
donc dans ce mémo
d'évolution et nous ne pouvons que
soutenir les objectifs de fond de ce
texte
il faut néanmoins bien mesurer l'impact
de la loi que nous votons nous devrons
trouver un chemin étroit entre la
consultation publique qui tient compte
des observations des citoyens et la
nécessité et lanester efficacité de la
décision publique qui ne doit pas être
bloqué par des dispositions que nous lui
imposons par ailleurs ce projet de loi
tire la conséquence de 4 décision du
conseil constitutionnel rendue dans le
cadre de la procédure de question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité le
dispositif des qpc est à mettre au rang
des progrès institutionnels voulu par la
majorité précédente est porté par le
groupe centriste du sénat
grâce aux qpc nous sommes certains
certes contraint de ligier ferrer mais
nous ne faisons pour améliorer la
sécurité du 4 juridique qui entoure la
société ainsi même si les délais sont
parfois cours les qpc permettent de
justifier pour une fois la procédure
accélérée
en effet les quatre décisions du conseil
sont applicables au 1er janvier 2013
pour les décisions d'ordre réglementaire
et au 1er septembre 2013 pour les
décisions individuelles concernant ces
dernières le délai suffisamment long
pour que ni la procédure accélérée
ni le recours à une ordonnance ne soit
justifiée j'y reviendrai dans une ma
deuxième partie le champ d'application
juridique du dispositif a besoin d'être
clarifiées afin de supprimer le recours
à une ordonnance pour légiférer
j'en viens maintenant au champ
d'application de ce projet de loi est
principalement au dispositif de
l'article 1er
le processus de consultation du public
projet proposé à cet article ne concerne
que les décisions publiques de niveaux
réglementaires et les décisions dites
d'espèce les décisions dite individuelle
en sont très clairement exclu et sont
concernés par la demande d'habilitation
à légiférer par ordonnances de l'article
7 du projet je ne comprends pas ce
découpage toutes les décisions publiques
ayant une incidence sur l'environnement
sont concernés par la décision du
conseil constitutionnel
comme je le rappelais dans les débats
notre commission ce découpage artificiel
certaines décisions n'appartiennent à
aucune catégorie
mieux vaut parler de décisions publiques
ayant une incidence environnementale
c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé un premier
amendement à l'article 1er de manière à
élargir le dispositif à toutes les
décisions
cet amendement répond également à une
demande apparu dans les observations
recueillies dans la consultation
publique sur ce projet de loi puisque
vous êtes souvenir normalement à cette
nouvelle procédure
selon l'étude d'impact de ce texte un
quart des remarques concernent le champ
d'un matériel d'application du texte et
notamment l'inclusion des décisions
individuelles
de plus le dispositif relatif aux
décisions individuelles est repoussée à
une habilitation ordonnance cette
procédure des saisies de législateurs de
son rôle et nous pouvons nous en
satisfaire le groupe centriste du sénat
s'est toujours opposé aux ordonnances
c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé un amendement
miroir à celui de l'article 1er
supprimant intégralement l'article 7
comme la rapporteure le souligne dans
son rapport le conseil constitutionnel
reconnaît dans une décision de 1999 que
l'urgence est au nombre des
justifications que le gouvernement peut
invoquer pour recourir à l'article 38 de
la constitution on le test que nous
examinons a été adopté en conseil des
ministres le 3 octobre dernier le
dispositif relatif aux décisions
individuelles doit être adopté avant le
1er septembre 2013
je ne suis pas sûr que les onze mois
c'est pense de date soit un véritable
motif d' urgence justifiant une
ordonnance pense qu'à une fragilité
importante à ce sujet en outre dans deux
décisions de 1977 de 1986 le conseil a
également exigé que le gouvernement
doivent indiquer avec précision au
parlement lors du dépôt d'un projet de
loi d'habilitation pour la justification
de la demande présentée par lui quelle
est la finalité des mesures qui se
propose de prendre sur cette base je ne
suis pas convaincu que l'article 7 nous
présente suffisamment de garanties de
précisions
du dispositif pour nous dessaisir
aveuglément de notre pouvoir
qui plus est sur un texte qui concerne
une question de consultation du public
c'est plus que surprenant c'est plus que
surprenant si manifestement un réel
manquements vis-à-vis du parlement en
conséquence et pour éviter toute censure
du conseil constitutionnel sur cette
habilitation que ne peux que vous
inviter à supprimer cet article
à moins que le gouvernement ne nous
fassent connaître plus précisément ses
intentions en terme de décisions
individuelles
enfin le dispositif de consultation du
public soulève en numéro un lui même
encore quelques questions comme le
démontrent les modifications apportées
par notre commission
au delà de la question du champ
d'application de nombreuses questions
restent en suspens après nos débats en
commission
concernant les délais minimums de
consultation notre commission dans un
premier temps les avait doublé à la
suite des dernières observations on
irait vers une solution médiane de 21
jours je pense qu'un doublement du délai
ne sembleraient totalement
contre-productif et en adoptant un
dispositif trop long nous allons bloquer
toutes les décideurs publics qui relaie
alors tendance à se saisir de la
procédure d'urgence la commission
également souhaitées sous l'impulsion de
nos collègues du groupe crc que les
conseils municipaux concernés soient
informés et consultés
c'est une bonne mesure il faudra
néanmoins régler la question des délais
de consultation là encore problématique
enfin l'initiative du rap de la
rapporteure la notion de tenu compte a
été introduite dans le texte
7 je suis convaincu que cette notion
même s'il est séduisante vins trop dur
un grand nombre de recours juridiques de
la part de nos constituants concitoyens
contre les décisions prises
l'étude d'impact du gouvernement
considère que la synthèse prévue
permettra à toute personne de constater
dans quelle mesure ces observations
d'influencer la décision adoptée cette
remarque de bon sens me semble
suffisante et devrait nous permettre de
ne pas ajouter la notion voulue par le
rapporteur
voilà l'importance et la participation
des coûts bertin il faut tout de même y
ajouter l'art et la manière pour que
cette participation soit utile et
efficace en ce début d'examen du texte
je ne suis pas sûr que toutes les
conditions soient totalement 1 réunit
ainsi le gros que lui des us et se
prononce prononcera sur ce texte en
fonction du sort réservé à ces
amendements notamment sur l'article
c'est madame la ministre vous avez parlé
de parler de démocratie participative
je pense qu'avant de parler de
démocratie participative on pourrait
parler de démocratie normale la
démocratie normale c'est de respecter
les fondements de de la répartition des
pouvoirs
le droit de légiférer appartient au
parlement et je suis vraiment très déçu
que nous soyons pas cet article 7
écarté de la discussion des décisions
individuelles d'autant plus qu'elles
concernent surtout les collectivités
territoriales et que le sénat est quand
même là pour les défendre
merci monsieur henri tandonnet dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur raymond vall
madame la ministre monsieur le président
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
je m'exprime en ce moment au nom du
groupe rdse et bien entendu au titre de
cette présidence cette commission non
madame la ministre que dont je voudrais
vous rapporter le fait qu'elle a
travaillé avec beaucoup
disons de conviction dans des conditions
difficiles et je voudrais commencer par
les remercier tous mes collègues cette
commission qui ont je crois dernier le
sens de l'intérêt général mais aussi
voulu préserver l'efficacité de l'action
dont le présent projet de loi tire les
conséquences de quatre questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité
pardon récente l'une du monde 2011 et 3
autres datant du mois de juillet dernier
elles présentent toutes un trait commun
la méconnaissance du principe de
participation du public principe qui
trouve ses origines en droit
international avec la déclaration de rio
de 1992 et la convention aarhus du 25
juin 98 a three fier par la france en
2002 en droit national
nous disposions déjà d' enquête publique
ou de concertation publique et la loi
barnier du 2 février 1995 à appliquer ce
principe au projet qui ont une incidence
importante sur l'environnement ou
l'aménagement du territoire si nous
devons tous nous réjouir face à la
confirmation de la valeur
constitutionnelle du principe de
participation du public prévues à
l'article 7 de la charte de
l'environnement de 2004
le liquidateur doit à nouveau se pencher
sur son application et notamment sur son
effectivité
en effet le conseil constitutionnel a
jugé certaines dispositions du code de
l'environnement contraire à ce principe
elle concerne tout d'abord les décrets
de nomenclature les projets de
prescriptions générales et techniques
des installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement les fameux
eee pc et décret sur la délimitation des
zones de protection des aires
d'alimentation de captage d'eau potable
et des zones d'érosion ainsi que leur
programme d'action
enfin une décision concerne les
dérogations à la protection des espèces
animales et végétales
dans tous les cas les sages du conseil
constitutionnel ont considéré que
l'application du principe de
participation du public n'était pas
garanti pour l'édition réglementaires
qui ont une portée générale
la publication du projet de décision
avant la saisine de l'organe consultatif
concerné n'a pas été jugée suffisante
actuellement ces procédures ne prévoit
pas le recueil des observations du
public et ne consacre qu'une branche du
principe de participation à savoir le
droit à l'information la participation à
proprement parler est ignorée par ces
dispositions
or ils reviennent à la loi de définir
les conditions et les limites de la
participation à l'élaboration des
décisions publiques ayant une incidence
sur l'environnement le projet de loi
aurait pu se borner à rectifier le tir
et régularisés en quelque sorte les
dispositions du code de l'environnement
qui sont abrogés à partir du 1er janvier
mais ce texte qui est proposée va plus
loin puisqu'il anticipe d'éventuels
censure inspiré par les mêmes motifs en
effet l'article
elle me semble un du code de
l'environnement prévoit une procédure
analogue à celle qui ont été censurés
pour les décisions réglementaires de
l'état et de ses établissements publics
c'est à dire une publication du projet
de décision avant saisine de l'organe
consultatif compétentes
cependant il convient de garder en
mémoire que cette procédure n'est que
supplétives elle s'applique uniquement à
l'absence de discussion particulière
ainsi l'article 1er procède à sa
réécriture en rendant systématique le
recueil des observations des citoyens
dans un délai qui permette à ces
derniers de participer pleinement et à
l'administration de les prendre en
compte l'article l 212 1 du code de
l'environnement prévoyait déjà cette
modalité de participation elle sera
désormais généralisé mais aussi
améliorer
en outre le champ d'application de
l'article l121 1 du code de
l'environnement était en aux décisions
d'espèces catégorie d'actes
administratifs qui ne sont ni
réglementaire ni individuelles
il convient de saluer donc l'obligation
pour l'administration de produire une
note de présentation du projet de
décision non technique c'est notre
vocation à expliquer clairement les
enjeux environnement
tout est associé l'ensemble des citoyens
aux décisions de l'état et de ses
établissements publics un délai minimum
de 21 jours est instauré pour les
observations qui parviendra
l'administration par voie postale et un
délai minimal a été en tout cas demandé
pour atteindre 30 jours pour les
observations émises par voie
électronique nous en rediscuterons
réduit rediscuterons tout à leur pardon
toutefois ce délai nous paraît un peu
long et risquent de rallonger les
procédures administratives à ses
concerts des observations émises par
voie postale
il me semble important d'associer les
personnes cela a déjà été dit qu'ils ne
sont pas équipés d'une connexion
internet pour qu'ils ne peuvent s'en
servir les mêmes droits doivent leur
être accordé et c'est pourquoi un
amendement du rdse vise à rendre
obligatoire l'affichage cela est
également demandée par ma collègue
didier donc l'affichage dans les mairies
tout cas concernés les préfectures pour
que les consultations prévues par ce
projet sur les décisions administratives
puissent être effective
seuls les horaires et les lieux de
consultation seront affichés et non
l'ensemble bien sûr du document
l'article tel que modifié par la
commission du développement durable mais
qui a vu en début d'après midi qui a du
pardon examiner les amendements proposés
par le gouvernement
donc améliore également la transparence
du processus de décision nous verrons
comment nous avons pu conjuguer les
amendements du gouvernement et ceux de
prix par la commission et par donc 7e
améliorations consistent à la
publication de ces observations sécu
sécurisé
juridiquement cette modalité de
participation car il devient alors
difficile de reprocher administration de
ne pas avoir consulté les citoyens en
bonne et due forme par ailleurs lorsque
la saisine d'un organe consultatif est
prévue la synthèse de ses observations
lui sera communiquée ce qui est je crois
une avancée importante
il est donc incontestable que ces
modifications ne font renforcer
l'effectivité du principe de
participation auquel nous sommes tous
attachés
l'association des citoyens aux décisions
qui ont une incidence sur
l'environnement n'est pas uniquement
garantie de leur transparence est
également garante de leur acceptabilité
ainsi ce projet de loi ne constitue pas
seulement une réponse urgente et
ponctuel à des décisions de justice mais
combien de sites et l'obligation de
communication du projet de décision
administrative aux conseils municipaux
concernés cela également été rappelés
toutefois nous ne sommes pas favorables
à ce que la vie de ces derniers soit
obligatoire même si en l'absence d'avis
au bout de 30 jours
celui ci soit réputé favorable il
convient de trouver un équilibre entre
l'information des élus locaux et le
risque de contentieux que peut engendrer
un cadre trop rigide dans nos
territoires nous sommes tous concernés
par des décisions de l'état
comme parfois une incidence locale
importante mais l'impact de ces
décisions ne justifie pas toujours une
telle mesure
il ne faut pas mes chers collègues que
sous couvert de participation et de
transparence on étale dans le temps la
prise de décision cela a été rappelé
tout au long des débats de notre
commission
je pense notamment qu'en matière
d'éolien terrestre domaine dans lequel
se multiplient les recours abusifs sur
les zones de développement de l'éolien
alors que le recours n'est pas toujours
dans la plupart des cas rejeté par les
tribunaux mais en attendant ces
décisions nous avons également beaucoup
rappelant commission de justice font
perdre un temps considérable
si nous sommes favorables à une
participation du public effective et la
transparence des décisions qui ont peu
d'impact sur l'environnement
il ne convient pas d'instaurer un
système dans lequel les seules voix qui
s'expriment sont celles opposées au
sujet car malheureusement nous sommes
confrontés aux mêmes opposants sur des
projets qui souvent ne les concerne pas
et parfois de très loin
mais dans l'opposition est devenue une
raison d'être
n'oublions pas que le principe de
participation est avant tout censé
assurer la prise en compte de l'intérêt
de tous et non pas celle de certains
intérêts particuliers enfin le
gouvernement sera habilité par vos
ordonnances vous l'avez préciser tout de
l'homme la ministre avec des engagements
que nous avons bien entendu
donc le gouvernement sera habilité
adoptée par voie d'ordonnancé des
modifications nécessaires pour rendre
effective la participation du public
en ce qui concerne les décisions
individuelles
sur laquelle mon collègue temps donné
s'est beaucoup exprimée et reviendra
tout à l'heure ainsi que toutes les
autres décisions publiques qui ne
tiennent pas sur l'environnement et qui
ne sont pas inclus dans l'article l100
20 du code de l'environnement comme par
exemple les décisions des collectivités
locales et l'on comprend que le sénat
puisse en quelque sorte s'émouvoir de
ces ordonnances
si le procédé peut être contesté malgré
vos engagements sur lesquels nous
rediscuterons tout à l'heure il est vrai
que l'abrogation des dispositions qui
autorise les dérogations à la protection
des espèces animales et végétales et qui
sont des décisions individuelles
interviendra à partir du 1er septembre
2013 et qu'il faut donc réagir
pour conclure le présent projet de loi
renforce donc la démocratie
environnementale participative sans
ignorer la représentation nationale
il est à ce titre équilibré car si les
citoyens doivent disposer du droit de
décider des projets qui peuvent avoir un
impact sur leur santé et leur bien-être
les membres du groupe rdse considèrent
que la démocratie représentative demeure
la meilleure expression de l'intérêt
général
merci merci monsieur le président val
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur ronan dantec
madame la ministre monsieur le président
madame la rapporteure chers collègues
toute personne a le droit dans les
conditions et les limites définies par
la loi d'accéder aux informations
relatives à l'environnement détenues par
les autorités publiques et de participer
à l'élaboration des décisions publiques
ayant une incidence sur l'environnement
en adoptant cette phrase incluse dans la
loi de 2005 qui donnait donc une force
constitutionnel à la charte de
l'environnement le parlement avait alors
clairement affirmé sa volonté d'inscrire
la constitution française
dans le droit fil de la convention d'un
russe ratifiée par la france en juillet
2002 très exactement dix ans après le
sommet de la terre à rio
cette convention des nations unies
s'appuyer sur le chapitre 10 de ce très
beau texte que res la déclaration finale
de rio en 1992 gelard site
la meilleure façon de traiter les
questions d'environnement et d'assurer
la participation de tous les citoyens au
niveau qui convient ainsi notre
discussion du jour ne doit pas se
résumer au fait d'adopter en procédure
accélérée une loi d'application
permettant de résoudre un certain nombre
de contentieux juridiques et de censure
du conseil constitutionnel mais bien
d'affirmer notre volonté politique de
répondre aux grands enjeux
environnementaux et de considérer que
pour ce faire il est absolument
nécessaire d'y associer étroitement les
citoyens ce n'est pas totalement notre
culture autant le reconnaître
la tradition française a fait de l'état
le garant unique de l'intérêt général et
nous avons construit un système de lois
et de grands corps d'état qui est censée
répondre à toutes les interrogations car
des dents détenteurs du savoir et du
pouvoir c'est donc bien le savoir qu'il
s'agit ici de partager et donc
probablement aussi un peu le pouvoir
ce texte s'inscrit donc bien dans une
forme d'évolution pour ne pas dire
révolution le mot a été utilisé avant
moi révolution culturelle et ce n'est
pas si simple
un certain nombre d'événements récents
le montre d'ailleurs clairement j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
ce texte allant dans le bon sens le
groupe écologiste le votera sans hésiter
et en espérant qu'une majorité claire se
dégage pour l'adopter
je rappelle d'ailleurs que lors du vote
sur la charte de l'environnement
c'était le gars la majorité de droite de
l'époque en 2005 qui avait porté ce
texte voulu par jacques chirac
les écologistes avaient d'ailleurs
soutenus par leurs votes cette charte de
l'environnement
c'était un peu moins vrai pour les
autres groupes de gauche mais c'était
une autre époque et je ne veux donc pas
qu'aujourd'hui le consensus sera encore
plus grand le travail constructif en
commission je salue la rapporteur qui va
nous rejoindre le travail constructif en
commission nous a d'ailleurs montré le
chemin avec déjà plusieurs améliorations
du texte notamment sur le temps du débat
public
beaucoup trop courts et que nous avons
donc un peu étendu probablement pas
encore assez mais nous verrons à l'usagé
dans la discussion à venir
cette séance peut d'ailleurs nous donner
l'occasion d'autres améliorations
le groupe écologiste ainsi proposé
plusieurs amendements comme sur
l'extension de l'accès à l'information
détenue par les entreprises soumises à
icp surtout un point essentiel nous
semblait être la nécessité de doter
l'ensemble du dispositif d'un organisme
garant qui en garantissant le suivi des
procédures apportera aux citoyens
l'assurance que sa mobilisation et ces
avis seront pris en compte
c'est un point important qui nous
rapprochera des pays les plus en avance
sur ces questions par exemple madame la
rapporteure l'avait cité le québec a mis
en place en 1978 un bureau d'audiences
publiques sur l'environnement organe
consultatif et indépendant chargé
d'informer et de consulter la population
se battent organise des consultations
des débats innove en s'appuyant sur les
nouvelles technologies de l'information
mais met aussi en place des procédures
de médiation car il ne s'agit pas juste
de recueillir des avis en laissant
l'état ou toutes autres décideurs seul
juge de leur utilisation
s'il ya bien une logique cette charte de
l'environnement c'est de créer le
processus qui permettent des projets
acceptés
parce que partager comme le disait la
rapporteur de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale en 2004 madame
kosciusko morizet en l'occurrence
la participation ne doit pas avoir lieu
à un moment où les choix ont été faits
par l'autorité publique
on ne peut mieux dire demander un avis
et ne pas en tenir compte
c'est s'exposer ensuite à bien des
difficultés imaginons par exemple un
grand projet du genre aéroportuaire pour
lequel on commencerait un grand débat
public sur le thème la plate forme
actuelle est saturé débat qui se
conclurait par le fait que finalement
non cette plateforme ne l'est pas et ne
le sera jamais mais que malgré tout les
promoteurs poursuivre et leurs projets
mais avec de nouveaux arguments qui
n'était pourtant pas au coeur du débat
public
imaginons toujours une étude
coûts-bénéfices pièce réglementaire
adossé à l' enquête publique du même
projet quelques années après et
imaginons que ce calcul des bénéfices
soit fondée sur une valeur économique
donnait alors économiser pour les
heureux bénéficiaires de ce nouvel
équipement un prix jusqu alors jamais
connu et jamais utilisé dans d'autres
enquêtes de même nature rend s'en
rendant ainsi très précieuse extrêmement
précieuse leur gagné par n'importe quel
touriste partant pour une semaine de
vacances en tunisie ou aux baléares
on serait évidemment surpris tout en
constatant évidemment sans s'être
évaluation du tarif horaire
le bilan de cette enquête coûts
bénéfices seraient fortement défavorable
au projet imaginons enfin que nous
soyons sur un territoire où les
procédures de médiation font rimer
l'acronyme du bape québécois b ape avec
bulldozer arasement policiers expulsion
s'étonnerait ton alors dans cette
situation que la participation du public
se transforme à la fin en manifestations
et occupations des lieux soyons donc
clair ce projet de loi de soi doit
s'inscrire dans une conception de notre
société où un état intègre et
transparent jouent le jeu de
l'information au risque de perdre le
débat public quand ces arguments sont
par trop faible c'est cette prise de
risque qui le rendra demain capables
aussi de faire partager ses projets et
de les rendre applicable quand ses
convictions sont justes
clairement expliqué s'il refuse de
prendre ce risque
l'état se prépare à de nombreuses
désillusions à travers le débat de ce
jour c'est donc bien la volonté de
passer un cap qui doivent guider notre
réflexion pour le bien de
l'environnement bien sûr mais aussi pour
le renforcement et la modernisation de
notre vie démocratique
c'est dans cet esprit que le groupe
écologiste soutiendra ce texte
merci monsieur dantec dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur jean luc fichet
monsieur le président madame la ministre
l'âme le rapporteur messire collègues je
vais prêter temps de cette intervention
ma voix aux interviews qui est devait il
ya cette intervention qui
malheureusement est empêché pour cet
après midi moins de deux mois après la
conférence environnementale le projet de
loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
présente une double volonté c'est
revivre la démocratie environnementale
mais aussi favoriser la rationalisation
législatives alors que le gouvernement
précédent n'a pas plu en compte les
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
dont la première était pourtant connue
dès l'automne l'automne 2011
votre gouvernement madame la ministre
s'est immédiatement emparée de cet enjeu
de la participation qui doit contribuer
à l'édification de l'écologie du 21e
siècle fondée sur la transparence le
dialogue et surtout la confiance à
rétablir entre tous les acteurs
au delà d inconstitutionnalité qui
rendent nécessaire adaptation de notre
législation
ce projet de loi relatif à la mise en
oeuvre du principe de participation du
public défini par l'article 7 de la
charte de l'environnement s'inscrit en
effet dans la perspective d'une
transition écologique et citoyenne la
feuille de route issue de la conférence
environnementales précise ainsi que le
passage à une participation effective
suppose d'une part que son rôle dans la
mise en oeuvre et le suivi des
politiques soient renforcés d'autre part
que soit levé plusieurs trains tenant
notamment à l'insuffisance de
l'information et de l'éducation du
public à la disponibilité des acteurs et
à la complexité des procédures
le principe de participation du public
déjà consacré dans le code de
l'environnement par la loi dite de
barnier en 1995 a été élevé au rang
constitutionnel par l'article 7 de la
charte de l'environnement pu confirmer
en l'espèce dans des décisions du
conseil constitutionnel et du conseil
d'état cet article 7 dispose que toute
personne a le droit dans les conditions
on est dans les limites définies par la
loi d'accéder aux informations relatives
à l'environnement détenues par les
autorités publiques et de participer à
l'élaboration des décisions publiques
ayant une incidence sur l'environnement
au terme de cet article le principe de
participation s'appuie sur deux piliers
cohérent et autonome
le droit d'accès à l'information
environnementale et la participation à
l'élaboration des décisions ayant une
incidence sur l'environnement le conseil
constitutionnel relève pour sa part que
les dispositions relatives à
l'information du public ne peuvent avoir
trait à la participation du public
en effet informé n'ai pas participé à
cet égard les amendements adoptés par la
commission du développement durable en
particulier ceux proposés par notre
excellente rapporteur et qui met en
oeuvre les principes de la
transversalité et de la traçabilité
représentent des apports fort utile je
voudrais cependant ajouté une position
entre insectes
il conviendra d'aborder rapidement dans
le cadre de partenariats entre les cinq
collèges du grenelle à savoir
l'éducation et la formation
car si l'information semble accessible à
tous la participation pourrait être
effective et significative exige des
connaissances intellectuelles et
culturelles parfois très pointues comme
le dispose l'article 8 de la charte de
l'environnement
la généalogie la participation puise ses
racines aussi dans la convention artus
qui rappelle que les états signataires
s'engagent à garantir les droits d'accès
à l'information sur l'environnement de
participation du public au processus
décisionnel et d'accès à la justice en
matière d'environnement
à ce titre je voudrais me féliciter une
nouvelle fois de la décision de la cour
de cassation dans le procès erika qui a
consacré la reconnaissance juridique du
préjudice écologique et propose de le
définir comme une atteinte directe ou
indirecte à l'environnement dans le
cadre du projet de loi relatif à la
responsabilité environnementale
le sénat avait pour sa part été à la
pointe de ce combat en donnant
collectivités la possibilité d'exercer
les droits reconnus à la partie civile
en ce qui concerne les faits portant un
préjudice direct ou indirect au
territoire sur lequel ils exercent leurs
compétences et constituant une
infraction aux dispositions législatives
relatives à la protection de la nature
et de l'environnement ainsi qu'aux
textes pris pour leurs applications
l'affermissement et l'élargissement du
principe pollueur payeur devront
néanmoins être encouragée je sais
pouvoir compter sur vous madame la
ministre pour porter cette volonté voilà
pour l'examen du projet de loi mettant
en oeuvre le principe de participation
du public posé par l'article 7 de la
charte de l'environnement
un principe qui permet à chaque citoyen
non seulement d'accéder à l'information
environnementale mais encore et surtout
de participer à l'élaboration des
décisions publiques qui ont un effet sur
l'environnement
nous y reviendrons bien évidemment plus
largement dans notre journal de 19h un
journal présenté par delphine girard
bonne soirée à tous sur public sénat